all right blade Smiths I know you guys
are probably chomping it the bit to jump
into this but today we're going to do it
lent slowly and by that I
mean bit
by
bit in this first round of competition
you'll have to take at least three
different size drill bits and combine
them into a canister to make a Damascus
Billet from which to forge a signature
blade in your signature style that is
between 12 and 14 in in length good luck
blade Smiths your 3 hours starts
now all right be to these blad Smiths to
make Damascus billets taking three
different size drill bits loading them
into canisters I definitely want to
avoid any of the Milling bits or the
highspeed drill bits because I know
those are going to have a lot of
chromium in them so it's not going to
want to weld I'm going to go ahead and
choose the Jackhammer bit and some of
the old augers they're a little more
simple so not a lot to mess with with
the welds those augur bits out there are
really pitted with rust so there's a lot
of cleaning to do to get those nice
enough that they are going to weld well
to tell if these bits are hardenable
steel you need to look at the spark
pattern of the steel Sparks that are
long and bursting at the end are very
good steels for knife making I would say
you don't rely on that bit steel at all
for your Ed get that 1095 powder March
your can so you know where that 1095 is
sitting and just do decorative stuff on
find your Blade with the bits I've never
made knives out of bits like this before
so looking at these I know I have a
challenge in front of me I know some of
these bits are going to be mild still so
I need to put a layer of 1095 down on
the bottom put my bits in the middle and
then cover that with another layer of
high carbon steel then get the cap on
I'm going to keep the can on that that's
mild steel but I don't want my M steel
to be on The Cutting Edge so I weld a
tab on the top my handle that lets me
know where I want the top of my blade my
knowledge of canister is minimal but I
do know with any Forge weld you want to
leave it in the Forge long enough that
it gets hot to the middle so my rule of
thumb is 10 to 15 minutes on that first
weld to make sure that it's sets
correctly big blue is powerful and fast
I can get this steel moved quickly into
the shape I need but also I can make my
steel Way Too
Thin Bo there you go that's one way to
get that work stick off of it yeah but
now it's a fight with the tongs to get
it off the ground are you still using no
go ahead
okay now that my Billet is up to the
thickness that I'd like and the width
that I'd like I start forging in my tip
what Sawyer's doing right now is a
really good way to put a tip on if you
actually hang just a little bit of the
blade over the Anvil and you start
working in that tip your blade doesn't
slide away from you
I have a lot of hammer experience so I'm
very used to forging my tips in by
hand I'm pretty stoked everything looks
solid I'll go shape the tip I shape the
tank I think I'm going to go for a large
buoy I do a lot of buoys they're kind of
a iconic American knife I'm really
enjoying watching Justin work here every
step that he does has a purpose to it I
am kind of a cessive compulsive over
minute details at this point I'm feeling
pretty good so I want to grind off that
top layer and make sure there aren't any
surprises
no I look down and there's a damb
running through the blade one running
down to the tank I'm scared to death at
this point if I don't get this fixed
this will be something that will send me
home now he's grinding through all the
mild steel that was hiding those flaws
and he's coming up big on problems yeah
lots of bees are W back there so there's
some kind of crackage going on the only
thing I can do is weld this together and
hope that I got that
filled Sawyer's blade is
quenched I take it out and there's a
warp and it's not a small warp I need to
fix
this Justin blade is
quenched I get it from my straightening
jig and hope that everything comes out
straight Ben's blade is quenched three
two one BL Smith shut down your machines
drop your tools stop what you're doing
this first round is
over gentlemen welcome to the strength
test the cinder block chop to test the
strength and durability of your edges as
well as the overall construction of your
knives I'm going to be bashing them
mercilessly into these cinder blocks
remember this test is all about what
those cinder blocks do to your knives I
don't really care what your knives do to
the cinder blocks Justin you're up first
you ready for this let's do
it I would never in a million years try
and smash a center block with a knife is
the thing going to fall apart is it
going to crack is it going to chip we'll
see how it
goes
well Justin first things first it's all
in one piece nice job for that all the
welds are still tight and nice for it to
hold up this well in this test is is a
testament to your abilities well done
thank you so here how you feeling not
good I'm looking at the center blocks
and they seem scary they are big and
they're very hard and I'm super nervous
at this point about what's going to
happen to my blade this is
[Music]
crazy soer well
put this aside for just a second let's
talk about the rest of your knife the
weight on this was really good you did a
nice job reducing all of that mass the
handle is comfortable but the big issue
of course is the brake there is a weld
here that runs up here and through and
if you look at the end here there's a
dark spot that weld was incomplete it
didn't show up as a crack externally we
didn't see it but it was there and it
was just ready to to go yes
sir Sawyer your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure during our strength
test on the fourth strike but that
doesn't mean that you're out of this
competition just yet because Ben your
blade has to survive four strikes in
order for you to move forward in this
competition
Ben this is a crazy test I'm a nervous
wreck I know I got to make it four hits
on mine the dam is definitely scaring
me no see this world end in his crack F
mhm oh my Lord Ben's pointing out the
damp well how do you feel about the uh
Integrity of the blade I mean do you
want to test it I am praying that he can
still test my
blade well Ben there's a little issue
with your blade here seems to be a
delamination that runs perpendicular to
the
blade usually a crack in this position
would be an extreme stress Riser causing
a fracture almost
definitely it doesn't however go to the
other side of the edge so I've confirmed
with my colleagues
and I feel safe enough to give it a try
just tap it in just tap it in tap it in
no it's going to break the first hit I
don't know man no it
will w knees are
shaking I would have never thought
that Ben Congratulations by a kitty
whisker your blade survived Sawyer that
means that your blade doesn't make the
cut please exit the forge over here to
your
right I'm a little disappointed not
going to lie it's pretty sad I hate to
see a blade break appreciate
vient apparently there was just
something within the steel that just
didn't quite weld right but I loveed the
competition I had some so much fun doing
it s awesome job apprciate when I get
home I'm going to sleep for 13 hours
straight probably and then I'm going to
go to the shop and do some canister
[Music]
Damascus